thank you to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video when I came up
with the idea for this video I thought
oh maybe I'll pop down to office works
which is the big stationary shop here in
Australia and I'll buy myself a slide
rule to do this video with but luckily
just before I left I thought you know
what maybe just maybe I should check the
catalogue first to see if they sell
slide rules at office works and turns
out that they don't so that's how I've
ended up here today with a very
makeshift slide rule and this is just
some pieces of paper held together with
a piece of plastic but I actually cut
out of something I scrounged out of the
recycling this old croissant packet and
it's held together with a little bit of
BlueTEC at the back there I'll put a
link to where you can download the
template to make one of these yourself
if you so desire
but as I'm going to go through and solve
some old exam problems with this you'd
probably see that it's not quite
recommended I've become somewhat of an
expert in the last half an hour or so on
slide rules before there I knew nothing
about them and I'd never used one before
now I have mild competence at using one
to do things but it's been a bit of a
nightmare actually so if you have a news
one either I'd probably say you're not
missing out on too much but there's
probably a lot of people maybe even
watching this video and around that
actually remember slide rules in their
heyday and they were popular and what
was used to do sort of multiplication
division as well as things like
trigonometry and logs square roots
things like that
before our pocket calculators so I think
even in like the 50s and even up to the
70s you would see engineers with one of
these to do all their calculations with
apparently it's the slide rule and doing
arithmetic with it that got us to space
you know that were used by engineers
during like the NASA programs and things
like that so I guess we owe a lot to the
humble slide rule and maybe it's a shame
that I've never picked one up before and
had to play with it in a previous video
of mine I looked at an MIT entrance
exam from 1869 and I looked at the
algebra section if you've seen that
video then know that this exam I have
here and the questions I'm going to go
through with my slide rule are from the
arithmetic section of that same exam so
MIT 1869 it was actually on my previous
video about some 19th century arithmetic
that some people in the comments pointed
out to me the slide rule and reminded me
of something the log table as well which
I didn't actually mention at the time
but was probably offered to students
back then taking exams and might have
made things easier for them since they
didn't have the pocket calculator that
we might have in an exam today so let's
take a closer look at our slide rule
here most of it we're not going to use
today we're just going to focus on lines
C and D C is the one that slides and D
is the one here that it meets so you can
see that C and D are both on a log scale
because the distance between say 1 and 2
is much greater than the distances up
here later between like 8 & 9 this is
because this part of the slide rule
which is used for multiplication and
division is exploiting properties of
logs and specifically the property that
log of X plus log of y is equal to log
of X Y so if we want to find the product
X Y what we do is we can add the log of
X to the log of Y which we kind of do by
sliding it like this and then take the
antilog of what we get the product and
the scale is sort of set up so that it's
taking the antilog for you and all you
need to do is worry about sliding it
around
I think these scales up here a is to do
with squares and square roots and K is
to do with cubes and cube roots so let's
have a look at our exam now this is it
here these are our MIT arithmetic
questions if we look at question 1
find the sum then the difference and
then the product of the fraction 3 and
5/9 and 1 and 7
twenty-fourths and then divide that
first fraction by the second one so I'm
actually going to skip finding the sum
and the difference because I don't think
it's worth trying to use this slide rule
for that and instead we'll just look at
finding the product of these two
fractions now first we want to convert
them from being mixed into being like
improper fractions so let's do 3 times 9
which is 27 plus 532 over 9 that's going
to be multiplied by 24 plus 7 31 over 24
so our first difficult multiplication we
need to do is 32 times 31 let's do it on
our slide rule so we're going to take
the one on the C scale and slide it
along to the first number that we're
multiplying all the numbers need to be
less than 10 so we're actually going to
slide this one along to 3.2 and then
deal with fixing our decimal places
later so I've got my one on three point
two there and then we're going to take
this plastic slider and slide it across
to the second number that we're
multiplying which is 31 make sure
everyone stays in place 31 will be three
point one so that'll be right and here
actually it's extremely close to the end
and I'm going to say that's extremely
goes to the end of the scale I'm going
to say that's nine point nine five down
here on D so I'll put nine nine five and
I'm not writing nine point nine five
because I'm aware that what I'm
multiplying would give me a number much
bigger than that so I'm pretty sure it's
going to be that on there and then let's
do the bottom multiplication we're going
to do nine by 24 now this time if we
were to try and take this one
slide it over to nine then the rest of
our slide was going to be over here and
that's of no use to us so we're actually
going to use the other side the one on
the right and slide it back over to nine
try and get it good okay and then we're
going to take our plastic bit and slide
it over to two point four on the C scale
so two point four would be about there
and that corresponds on the D scale to
be two point one five if I would say so
they're just in there and I don't think
it's two point one five because that
wouldn't make sense with these numbers
and see if it makes sense for it to be
215 so that's actually our fraction that
we get as an answer I'm kind of
confident about these first two
significant figures but the third
significant figure I'll be honest was
kind of a guess so maybe not the most
accurate and I feel like most of that's
got to do with the precision here so
it's like flimsy pieces of paper and
this is barely holding together sensibly
but maybe if you had a more robust slide
rule you'd be more confident in your
last figure there so I actually just
looked up on my calculator what this
would be and it looks like it would be 9
9 2 over 216 so we were actually pretty
close there if we wanted to get some
more precision than our slide rule we
could use a log table which is this
crazy table over here and we're going to
use that in the next question to get a
little bit more accuracy but I think our
sort of approximation here was kind of
all right I'm going to skip dividing
this fraction by this one because it's
almost the same as what we've just done
instead of dividing I would suggest
multiplying by this fractions reciprocal
so that would make kind of a similar
calculation so I don't think you need to
see that again and stayed we'll do
number 2 multiply
seventy-three thousandths which would be
73 over a thousand by nineteen hundreds
which would be this okay so if we want
to do that we should exploit the
property of logs that the log of 73 plus
the log of nineteen will give us the log
of the product 73 times nineteen so if
we wanted to find this product here 73
times 19 then all we need to do is add
the logs together and then take the
antilog of the answer so let's try and
do that we're going to look up in our
log table what the log of 73 is now in a
similar way these numbers are all less
than 10 so let's have a look for 7.3 and
here it is here it's a little small but
it corresponds to a decimal number which
is zero point eight six three three now
one rule with using this table is that
if there were two significant figures
and the number we were taking the log of
then we do 2 minus 1 and we put a 1
before our decimal point so we're going
to be n minus 1 I believe so it's going
to be one point and then our number 8 6
3 3 add that to the log of 19 let's go
and find one point nine which will be
here that corresponds to 0.278 eight so
in a similar way that will be one two
significant figures 0.278 eight if we
add those together what we get is 3.14
to one that was suspiciously close to pi
there for a second
okay and that means that if we take the
antilog of this number here we should
end up with the product that we wanted
so we'd get another table which is our
anti-love table
you better hope you've got all these
handy and we're going to look up three
point one four to one but we're actually
just going to look up the part that's
after the decimal point in here so one
four to one point one four two and then
we're going to add on a one which is
adding on a zero so it's just going to
be one three eight seven
okay so what we're going to get back up
here is our answer for the product
seventy three times nineteen will be
this value it will be zero point one
three eight seven and then we have a
rule that works in Reverse so remember
this three you add one on to that
becomes four and we times our answer by
10 to the power of four
that works out our answer to just be one
three eight seven as the product between
those two numbers now remember what we
were actually doing was this up here so
this is actually equal to one three
eight seven over a thousand times a
hundred will be one one two three four
five
a hundred thousand and that is our
answer if we look at question three now
we're being asked to divide to eight
eight zero by zero point zero zero three
six now to do division on our slide rule
we just do the opposite of what we were
doing when we were doing multiplication
so what we want to do is line up three
point six on our C slider on top of
2.88 on our bottom line which is our D
and we'll see what we get there so we've
got three point six lining up with two
point eight eight roughly there and then
what we want to do is trace it along and
figure out what our one lines up with
now the one on the side is off the page
so that's that helpful we're going to go
to this one over here and we can see
that lines up almost perfectly with our
eight so our answer to this division
question is going to be eight something
and you can maybe need a bit of guess
and check on this I think that we're
going to have eight one two three four
five that feels kind of right but I'm
gonna go check on my calculator and see
and yes verifying on my calculator which
is not what you'd be allowed to do in
this exam looks like this is our right
answer here eight hundred thousand so
there you go there's three different
types of questions solve using either a
slide rule or a log table we've seen
division multiplication and
multiplication with a bit more accuracy
the rest of the questions here on this
exam I am going to leave as an exercise
for the viewer I'd like to thank
curiosity stream for sponsoring me to
make this video
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service with content that
covers areas such as science technology
nature history and lifestyle you might
enjoy curious minds science and society
where experts explore the impact of
scientific thought and developments for
my audience the first 30 days are
completely free if you go to curiosity
stream dot-com slash
tibeats and use the promo code tibbie's
during signup thank you to curiosity
stream and thank you for watching
you